hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk a little bit about my check
challenge or as I called it the five
days to fluency in check and I want to
bring you up to date on on what's
happening included in what's happening
is a happening yesterday I was driving
to work at an early morning hockey game
i'm in a hockey tournament the bc senior
games so far we've lost two games but I
came home and threw my equipment out
onto the out of the driveway to dry out
and the Sun and then downloaded some of
my regular listening from chess quiroz
class and headed off to work along the
winding road marine drive is quite windy
and there's a bus stop there and there
were these two girls hitchhiking you
know in their 20s and very rarely do you
see people hitchhike and and but they
looked so kind of pleading that I
stopped and picked them up and they come
in they said they've been waiting for an
hour because there aren't many buses
along this route and but I still had my
check interview playing through the
audio system in the car and they said oh
what's that is that the radio and I said
no I'm listening I'm learning check oh
you're learning jack we're from from the
Czech Republic wow I mean you know I hit
the jackpot so for the next 20 minutes I
was able to speak check with them in the
car I mean that was the first
spontaneous conversation and check that
I had ever had because I have spoken to
my tutors on skype but I had never
actually met someone and started
speaking Czech with them so I was just
done that was just like wow that was
tremendous like an almond and olman so I
was very pleased with that um we played
hockey again this morning at eight in
the morning so I had to get up very
early didn't sleep very well and we lost
again as I say but um before I get into
explaining again the five days to
fluency I also wanted to comment briefly
on a little sort of exchange on another
video that i made Reese
the a video that I put out in Russian
it's part of my series the seven secrets
to successful language learning and of
course the seven secrets are one if I
remember them now to put it enough time
to to do things that are interesting for
you three to notice what's happening the
language for to that grammar is more
important than vocabulary five is to be
patient six is to get the proper tools I
mean even YouTube is a proper tool mp3
player accessing good resources and the
seventh and final point is to be a
genuinely independent learner these are
my seven secrets and I'm doing them in a
variety of different languages I did
them did the series in Russian of course
it has Russian Cyrillic writing in the
title and one of the people who follows
my youtube channel said you know please
add subtitles to the Czech video under
this Russian video not sorry no he
didn't say please you should make
subtitles to your check video so I
replied first of all the video is in
Russian and second of all it takes too
much time to make subtitles I think
verbatim that's what I said so then this
other person comes on and says you seem
very rude you should lighten up have
some wine bring some life and let some
love into your life I don't know what
sort of thing I must say I got quite
annoyed at this and maybe I'm perceived
as a very nasty crotchety old guy which
is fine I don't mind being a crotchety
old guy why does everybody have to go
around being so you know it's nice to be
nice I'm nice to people I you know I'm
happy I'm I don't think i have an
unpleasant personality but you know
there's a limit like on the internet it
seems that everybody gets on everybody
else's blog and post Smiley's and Oh
brilliant blog wow that's just so good
and thank you and I don't know I just
don't do
and it doesn't bother me that some
people find me a little crotchety I like
crotchety people sometimes doesn't
matter to me but if someone put out a
video in a language that I didn't
understand and I wasn't sure what the
language was i would say what language
is that i wouldn't say if someone spoken
arabic i wouldn't say please no no
please you should make subtitles to your
Farsi video I would do that if I wasn't
sure whether it was Farsi or Arabic or
whatever I would say what language is
your video and insofar as subtitles it's
a lot of work to make subtitles I mean
it's a lot of work to make these videos
I mean people have other things to do in
their lives and I'm not obliged to make
subtitles so but what considered by and
then of course in this typical internet
environment the person who ever wrote
you know lighten up you know it should
be nice to people like 11 people get on
there and give it a thumbs up this whole
thumbs up businesses another thing that
I find it on who are these people I
don't know these people they don't
announce who they are they don't provide
any opinion I think Steve is a jerk I
disagree with Steve nothing just thumbs
up it's sort of like a gang on ganging
up piling on type mentality which I'm
not a fan of however getting back to the
original topic which is the five days to
fluency all right five days to fluency
no one in the right mind believes that
you can become fluent from zero in five
days however everything that happens in
life in a five day period or a ten day
period is the result of a lot of
circumstances that lead up to that
period so I remember many years ago
reading a book about the Russian
Revolution which was called ten days
that shook the world those were the
presumably that 10 days surrounding when
they both of it Bolsheviks took power
but there was a long period leading up
to that you can even talk about the
liberation of the serfs and the
you know political assassinations in
Russia and the existence of different
political parties and you know the war
between Russia and Japan the First World
War there's a bunch of stuff that led up
to those 10 days so in my case I have
five days in Prague those are the only
that's the only time I have in Prague so
I set myself as a goal that I'm going to
prepare as much as I can so that when i
arrived in Prague I understand the
language I understand the radio I
understand maybe not a hundred percent
it's never one hundred percent but much
of what's going around me so that when I
hit the streets of Prague I'm able to
function and then I can then convert or
significantly improve my ability to
speak Czech because i already have
prepared so well and so my preparation
has consisted of essentially over the
last year of an awful lot of listening
and reading our stats at link tell me
that i have read on link over 750,000
words i have also read on our we're
testing our beta version of the new
improved lincoln there i've read about
250 thousand words so I mean a million
words on on lincoln i'm reading other
books in check so i've read the
equivalent of i don't know 10 12 15
books in check most of it on the
computer where i am looking up words i'm
seeing the words that i previously
looked up i'm reviewing those words i'm
clicking on them for examples doing a
bunch of stuff that helped those words
sink in so i did that for most of the
past year an hour and i'm really
probably closer to two hours a day and
in the last month or so six weeks i've
started stepping up my online
discussions in check with a number of
tutors and i'm doing this a because it's
good for me at this stage i have enough
words that I can
actually understand what they're saying
and and I can kind of express my ideas
and we're not just talking about what my
name is and this is a pen and you know
the sun's out and stuff so it's actually
interesting we talked for an hour even
an hour and a half and it's an
interesting conversation because I
understand what they're saying I can
express myself we have an interesting
conversation and at the end of it all I
get a list of all of my mistakes which I
can study and I do that plus i continue
daily listening to you know these
programs from chess quiroz classy
activity nozzoli argument II and Mozilla
Maria tolki chesko minerals tea and
those is just in an inexhaustible supply
of audio and and transcript for check so
with that now I and the other reason of
course that I have these four or five
tutors that I'm speaking to is that I
have to organize those five days in
Prague so that I meet as many Czech
people as possible and unlike Benny I
don't think it's possible just to go out
them randomly find people to talk to and
expect that they're going to humor me
because i'm learning check to the extent
that i can do that that's great to the
extent that i can go to a pub and meet
people tremendous and I'm certainly
going to try to do it but I want to make
sure i have people to talk to so i'm
going to have lessons yes and our
lessons consists simply of discussions
followed by a list of all the words that
i didn't use property so that i can
bring them into into link and study them
and so that's going to be my regime
there i've already spoken to yarda one
of our tutors that link one of our
members we're going to have a video upon
arrival and a video at the end maybe at
a pub or somewhere i'm going to
basically video myself talking to random
people that's the plan and just see to
what extent my check improves during
that five day period I will arrive
already with an ability to speak as the
result of the work that I put in this
past year and then hopefully it'll
improve the purpose of doing this is a
it's partly publicity of course let's be
honest but it's because
I think that this approach is a very
good way to tackle a language set
yourself a goal I want to go to Mexico
Beijing Seoul Korea Heidelberg Germany
it doesn't matter Ankara Turkey I want
to go there in six months a year 18
months it doesn't matter therefore when
I go there I want to be able to
understand the language well enough that
I can actually take advantage of being
there so in order to do that I'm now
going to work very hard primarily on my
passive knowledge my ability to
understand both the written and the
spoken language this means a large
vocabulary albeit a passive vocabulary
it's great to have a passive vocabulary
because you have to understand what
people are saying to you otherwise you
can't very well maintained up a
meaningful conversation so to me it's a
pattern it says five days to fluency
which can be two weeks it can be a month
it doesn't matter the whole point is
once you set the target of when you're
going to go there then you spend the
intervening period developing this
tremendous this deep passive knowledge
of the language and if you can't afford
to go anywhere then you can still do
this because you can say all right my
five days to fluency is going to be five
or six or ten days but what I'm going to
do is I'm going to set a period of time
a year from now when I'm going to
massively immerse myself in the language
where day after day I'm going to do
nothing but listen and read in the
language I'm going to speak to people
via Skype so I'm going to organize
myself so that at some point in the
future I can have this massive immersion
listening reading speaking you know
total concentration on my target
language so I just think that's an
interesting way to motivate yourself and
and to set a very sort of specific goal
and to put in place a program so that
you can achieve a cheap metal so I will
be from time to time reporting on my
progress and certainly when in
I will be making videos so that people
can see how this works and hopefully
this can inspire other people to do the
same and we can call it five days to
fluency it doesn't matter whether it's
five or six or ten or twenty but people
who would say to themselves and maybe
tell us and others here who follow this
channel at YouTube ok I'm going to learn
Thai I'm going to learn Portuguese and
my target is 12 months 18 months and my
five days to fluency period of
conversation is going to be at this
point and then keep a little record of
it and so we can see how they do okay I
went a little over today thank you for
listening bye for now